you know your personality creates your personal
reality that's it and your personality is made
with how you think how you act and how you
feel so if you keep thinking the same way
you keep acting the same way you keep feeling
the same way everything stays the same in your
life because nothing changes in your life
until you change right so turns out if you
keep thinking the same way making the same
choices doing the same things creating the
same experiences and feeling the same emotions
or responding to your life in the exact same way
you keep doing that your biology tends to get
more rigid we fire and wire the same service
we hardwire our brain and they it only takes a
small stimulation or a small fodder a response
to someone or something and like a sequence of
thoughts it just turns on automatically hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos because
in my first business I struggle to believe in
myself I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was watching the
successful stories of entrepreneurs they gave
me the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite honestly I
still need their stories and motivation today as
well so today let's live your best believe life
and learn the secrets to a successful day enjoy
your biology and your neurochemistry your
hormones your genes everything stays the
same because you're the same so crisis and Trauma
is always the thing that gets a person to really
start looking at how do I really change right
so so we want to tell people let's not wait for
that let's let's learn and change in a state of
growth and inspiration so so if you keep doing
those same things over and over again the middle
life period we we become very very programmable
so in order for us to change we have to become
conscious of how we think we have to become
really aware of how we behave what our habits
are even how we speak now this is a tough one
we have to really look at the emotions that we
live by every single day and and say wow this
this actually could be unworthiness this could
actually be guilt but if you're too busy with
your cell phone and your social media and you're
too busy with your kids and running around and
everyone your environment can distract you from
these feelings so my interest is to get people to
retreat from their lives right just for five seven
days and and remove the constant stimulation in
their external environment that reminds them
of who they think they are as a personality
to separate themselves from the people they know
and the places they go and the things they do at
the exact same time and then fill their brain
with knowledge and information and then remind
them that they're actually creating their life so
if your personality creates your personal reality
and that means that if in order for you to change
your personal reality you got to change your
personality secret number two is learn to wind
down Brandon bershard have you ever had difficulty
winding down at the end of a busy day and you feel
like gosh I can't sleep because of it or you're
not getting great sleep or you just feel like
constantly frazzled at the end of the day that
you just wish you could have some sense of Peace
amidst all the chaos of the day well what are you
gonna do I got four ideas for you today the first
one is just you must you must must must set up a
discipline a routine that you do every night if
you're ever going to make it any better the hopes
that one day we're just gonna you know wander
into a perfect evening where everything's you
know flowers and and calm and meditation practice
and everything's a perfect yoga studio around the
house that's not gonna happen unless you have a
distinct setup intention that every night you're
going to follow a routine you know you talk to
parents and you talk about you know their kids
and one of their favorite parts of their childhood
is when the kids finally got on a routine and when
they got a routine the parents finally felt like
oh at least we can plan a dinner or at least we
know when we're going to bed it's like as soon as
you establish routines in your life you start to
be able to feel better well the same thing goes
with your evenings your evenings shouldn't be a
hot mess of like oh we watched the show now let me
go check Facebook and let me do some Instagram and
now let me go do this and oh random it's like
if there's a bunch of random things at the end
of the night what you're doing is firing off the
dopamine molecule and hormone in your brain that
says I like novelty and all these new things are
firing up your brain not winding it down so the
more Randomness you have at the end of the night
the less likely you'll sleep well the more likely
your brain will be activated and want to do more
things it'll be more difficult to chill out so
make sure you to have some type of routine here's
what I recommend the first point transition from
the busy day you need to have your transitions
for some people that is you come home you get
in the house you go to the gym you work out then
you come back home and now now there's a break
from work versus home other people they drive to
their house they get into the house they meditate
for 20 minutes 30 minutes 10 minutes whatever
it takes other people take a quick nap whatever
it is or even some other people just take a walk
around the house a couple times and just focus on
releasing their thoughts and the stress from the
day other people stretch and move whatever it is
you got to have that transition routine so what is
it you need to have something says I finished the
work of the day I'm going to wind down now and you
must activate a habit for me it's meditation and a
walk that keeps me sane so when I get home from
a day's work even if I'm working from home but
I know I'm done now I meditate I walk around the
block and I'm in a good place it's just something
I immediately do and I highly recommend it to
you as well next idea big idea don't get stuck in
social media don't get stuck in front of screens
if you want to wind down again the way to do that
is to avoid Randomness and Novelty lots of new
things so watching you know three seasons of a
show is not going to chill you out it's going
to create a little bit of anxiety and dopamine
where you're just like activated you want to avoid
looking as much as social media I just tell people
if you really want to chill out and like wind
down maybe one show that's okay cool but then read
a book or go for that walk or do something that
removes you from all the like the the crazy stuff
going on especially you know tweets or Instagrams
or scrolling through news feeds all that's only
firing you up not winding you down third big
idea is make sure you have something that you
do for gratitude practice you know one great way
to increase your happiness but also help you calm
down is gratitude so do you have a gratitude
Journal you can do at the end of the night
do you have a moment where you can just take
and just write down a few things you were happy
for for the from the day maybe a few things you
learned and some people if you just can you write
down a few things you got to do the next day just
to get them off your mind so you're not laying in
bed going what am I supposed to do tomorrow and
then you activate all the things you're supposed
to do get that on a piece of paper somewhere
just get it off your brain put it away and now
you don't have to deal with it anymore last idea
use the environment of your home to Wind You Down
dim the lights put on the house music that's
calming music like those candles if you got
the candles drop the temperature down to 68 or
69 degrees so your body gets ready for bed when
you get into bed have your moment of gratitude
where you think and complete the day where you say
this was a good day this day is now over I did
my best everything today did pass there's nothing
more I can do to influence this day this one is
done it is complete good job I'm thankful for
it I'm ready for bed tell yourself that like
give your let your brain go the day is done
and it releases all this expectation that your
mind wants to have to keep thinking at night so in
bed it's very important have the have that moment
where you go the day is done I did a good job
be grateful go to bed if you can have that
temperature set down make sure the room is dark
make sure you don't have any of those you know big
alarm clocks or casting light into the room I mean
go for a pitch black dark room at night it's been
proven in every sleep study to improve your sleep
and the depth of your sleep and Rejuvenation so
make sure pitch black room no lights no sound
if you think you need that Ambiance White Noise
then there's plenty of ways you can do that but
make sure there's no screen casting light as you
do that drop that temperature 68 69 degrees enter
your sleep from a moment of gratitude you'll feel
a lot better tomorrow you feel rejuvenated you'll
feel ready to go because if you can wind down
well at the end of the day then the next day
when you wake up you'll be like I'm ready for
the charge life secret number three is develop
an ORS mindset with Jay Shetty you've done so
much and really from what I observed even you
really started in 2000 and I'd say the the sort
of external social media content Journey started
in 2016. yes that is mad that is mad you've gone
from 2016 um making your first content tour in
2022 now just and you're This Global household
name as it relates to content self-improvement
meditation all of these topics right that's a
short period of time when you look back and you
try and connect the docs as Steve Jobs often did
about how Apple came to be in the little moments
and the little things whether it was a moment of
um good fortune or whether it was something that
you have spotted in hindsight and your character
why was Jay Shetty successful in such a short
period of time in such a big way give me the
honest practical answer I don't want anything I
want that why why were you successful so I'm gonna
give you the I'm gonna give you my monk answer and
then then I'm gonna give the media answer so and
then and I live by both right like you have to you
have to see things as both and that's why I love
my mom answer is I was really fortunate to meet
incredible people when I was young I met a few
people that absolutely transformed my life I'm
eternally indebted to them grateful to them and
I owe it all to them and so I give all my success
to them you know without meeting those amazing
mentors and those phenomenal thought leaders and
thinkers who are not famous who are not known who
are not present like they're not they're not in
the social media world they're not big names or
whatever those people you know those people if I
never met them none of this would have happened I
can see that's the emotion in your face when you
say this yeah I just I I really you know we
we skipped it earlier but I I just feel like
the gratitude that I have for people who saw
potential in me when I didn't see it myself
greatest gift you can you kill someone like I
today have self-awareness and I have confidence
and I know who I am and I I wasn't always like
that like there were tons of years where I was
insecure and you know I was bullied for being
overweight and I was bullied for being the only
Indian at school and there was so much like
baggage to do with just my body my language
I used and all this kind of stuff and to to
have someone notice that you may have something
I mean you've had that and that is just you you
like honor that person for the rest of your life
and the best thing is those people don't even want
it so you know the best thing about all of this is
the people there are not going oh yeah we did
that they're actually saying no no it's not us
like it's you and and I think that's the beauty of
that so I I have to say that I it's important that
I share that answer not because I'm trying to give
a more strategic answer but I think it's important
because it is a big part of it and so that would
be the monks that I met would be the coaches that
I met the guys that I met looking at it from a
very practical strategic standpoint shifting now
my parents forced me to go to public speaking
and drama school when I was 11 years old and I
really didn't want to go because I was shy I was
unconfident I was insecure about being on stage or
being in a public setting I actually loved acting
growing up I really enjoyed acting and doing
theater and things like that where I was playing
another character but being myself on stage that
was the last thing I wanted to do and my parents
saw that and they saw that as something that I
should work on so they forced me and my school
to enroll me in a public speaking course so from
the age of 11 through to the age of 18 for three
hours a day three days a week so nine hours a week
for seven years I went to public speaking school
really for seven years of my life I went to public
speaking school so when I look back at my ability
to communicate my ability to understand ideas and
by the way public speaking school is examination
based too so we had exams where they would give
you a topic 15 minutes before you have 15 minutes
to research a topic from the books in the room
that they give you because there was no smartphone
at the time when we were 11 12 years old and you'd
have to create a speech in 15 minutes about that
subject from the books that were in the room you
had to read from a book that you'd never read
before they'd pick a random page and they'd ask
you to read it out so the examination of a public
and this was at the London Academy of Music drama
and arts it's called Lambda and that's where I
studied for seven years so that's a very strategic
skill set that I had the time to develop thanks
to my parents you know like without my parents
that none of that would have ever happened and I
think that's a big part of why people hopefully
appreciate how I communicate ideas because I've
spent a lot of time understanding communication
but when I was 18 I had nothing to talk about so
even though I had all these tools and skills I
didn't really use them because I didn't care about
anything so sure I gave a good presentation at
University and work experience and an internship
but it was never something that brought me to life
and so then when I met the monks and I got
an opportunity to study The Vedas which are 5
000 years old and again we were put through
rigorous study we sat down we had to learn
verses we had to analyze purports commentaries
on Ancient scriptures we had to do comparative
analysis of religions and tradition like
when I was among we were massively trained
in philosophical analysis and that to me
gave me a real strength and confidence in
these ideas so some of the ideas I present
today that may sound simple they're based on
these really ancient deep truths that I've had
the time to Grapple with with the greats who
really understand them so that to me is a big
benefit I've had where I've had three years of
complete dedication to studying philosophy and
not just studying the intellectual areas but
the Practical and the applicable areas as well
so thanks to my monk teachers who gave me that
and then when I went to Accenture where people
were like Jay you're just a monk why did you go
to Accenture I had to pay the bills I couldn't
rely on my parents and you know my parents are
not wealthy that they could pay my ways
through life and I moved back into their
I moved back into my childhood bedroom when
I was 26. wow living with my parents with 25
000 18 000 pounds worth of debt and just feeling
that you know I was like what do I do now and I
applied to 40 companies that would have given me
a job I'm a first class honors degree student I'm
a straight A student and I was rejected from 40
companies because surprise surprise no one wanted
to hire a monk so everyone goes what are your
transferable skills sitting quietly and sitting on
the floor like no one needs that so 40 companies
say no to me Accenture finally give me a shot and
I meet someone called Thomas power and Thomas
power I don't know if you ever met him actually
he's london-based uh he started up like an early
LinkedIn kind of version called Academy and he
was he's very networked in London in the business
space definitely want to introduce you guys he's
awesome uh and he was brought in by Accenture to
train Us in social media and train Us in in this
new wave of this new thing that was happening and
it's really interesting because we've talked about
it me and him many times I'm going to have him
on my podcast soon and I realized I was like you
didn't really teach me much about social media but
you really taught me about breaking my mindset and
he would always repeat Napoleon Hill you become
what you think about and he'd always tell me that
he'd be like keep saying that to yourself and I'd
keep saying that to myself remember you become
what you think about you become and then I was
like oh what am I thinking about I'm not thinking
about anything so what am I going to become
nothing and and it was just really interesting
and so he would give me these little tools and
little things to play with he had another one
called uh ORS which he would say that successful
people have to be open random and supportive and
he'd say that most unsuccessful people are closed
selective and controlling CSC and he was saying
that when you live in a CSC mindset you limit your
growth but when you live in an ORS mindset open
random and supportive you expand your growth so
you'd encourage me to be open with strangers on
Twitter it encouraged me to be open with random
people with me at a conference and he was just
training me in behaviors and mindsets it wasn't
like how to post and what time to post and this
is how you make it wasn't how to make something go
viral like that wasn't it it was how to engage how
to push your comfort zone how to challenge your
fear why are you so uncomfortable to walk up to
that person and tweet them you know all of those
kind of things and I saw that my mind just became
open to the ideas he would always tell me you're
an entrepreneur I'd be like no I'm not no I'm not
meant to work for someone and so he would keep
pushing me until I'd get really angry with him
like you don't even know who I am only for me to
realize he saw something in me that I never saw
and then I'd say from there on that's kind of what
gets me to the beginning of it I would say that
for 10 years before 2016. I was making content and
delivering it in small venues in London so I had
an event in London at University called think out
loud every single week I would design a poster on
Photoshop I taught myself Photoshop and I'd
make a poster and I would talk about a movie
from a philosophical psychological and spiritual
perspective so I take a movie like Inception and
I'd break it down and 10 students would come every
week and then I teach meditation which I'd learned
from the monks and then 20 students would come and
then by the time I finished University a hundred
people came every single week to hear me break
down and this was no followers the events were
free I Was preparing for free doing everything
for free and I loved it and I got so much joy
and then afterwards when I was at Accenture I
ran an event in London called conscious living
and it was just a it was an event
which was probably like five pound on
a Friday night and again I was teaching
philosophy spirituality and meditation
okay five people turned up it wasn't University
anymore where you could go and deck the halls with
flyers and posters and the common room and the
community area so we'd get like five to ten people
every Friday night paying five to ten quid just
for the food that we gave and you know the posters
that we made just to cover the costs so for 10
years before I ever made a piece of content online
I've practiced rehearsed experimented grappled
challenged these ideas again and again and again
and again and again without any followers without
any money and without anything else coming from
it apart from the fact that I love it I love
the idea of reading a book and trying to make
it relevant so I would say that the biggest
reason is because I've done this for 10 years
offline before it ever went online so I've been
doing it for like 16 years and that doesn't count
the 11 year old public speaking classes also to
make sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in this video
as well as pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also give you
space to write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make sure
you're getting results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the description below
go click on on it and start building the momentum
in your life and your business I'll see you
there secret number four is set up your day
with Dean graziosi I've doubted myself a million
times I felt like an imposter a million times
I've had my own family look me in the eye and
say stop being a dreamer Dean that's for other
people he didn't go to college we don't come
from that kind of money you'll never be that
they don't say that when I land my own jet in
my hometown and my whole family gets off my own
plane right I don't say that to be a jerk I don't
you don't even see me do you ever see me post a
picture of my playing on my Instagram I'm not the
guy that holds up money or shows you in my plane
or my house that's the house of my dreams I don't
do that I don't want people to follow me because I
hold stacks of money on a on a Facebook ad right
I want people to know me for the heart I have
but I'm blessed to have more success than I ever
could a dream possible and I get to take care of
the people I love I got to put my own oxygen
mask on years ago and now I put it on a lot
more people than you'd ever know that's not all
I donate to we've done it in a lot of different
areas and this year I want to donate I don't
know about the feelings you have but who who
felt that in their heart when I shared what I
was able to do right who in here has a desire
to help other people once you're secure can I
give can I share something with you and I want
to share this today because it just feels on
my heart I'm going to tell you to be selfish
be selfish be selfish for the next three years
go get yourself strong go put your own oxygen
mask on put some money in the bank crush your
company be selfish with your time be selfish
with your income be greedy on the amount of
money you want to make I'm telling you be greedy
be selfish you know why because if you go all in
if you stop thinking I wish I could do more be
more go all in and make the money get secure
and put your oxygen mask on and what you can do
in five years from now what you can do in seven
years from now what you could do in 12 years from
now is unbelievable but we need this moment of us
we need this moment of getting ourselves so many
of us so many of you I see right now are the
most giving people you've ever any anyone knows
you're the person that gives the most you know
what you're doing you're putting oxygen masks on
everybody else and you can barely breathe you're
out there helping everybody let's do this let's
do this let's do this and you're barely breathing
you're like here's an oxygen mask here's an
oxygen mask when you need to hold it to your face
I love the story of Andrew Carnegie right what
did Andrew Carney get a certain pace of his life
you know what he said I'm going to spend half
the first half of my life making a ton of money
and I'm going to send the spend the
second half of my life giving it all away
if he would have if he would have felt guilty
if he would have not went for it he never would
have got to the ability to do the things that he
was able to do with his money I'm telling you be
greedy be selfish so you could be the least greedy
and the least selfish for the long run right what
is what does Tony always say and I think he got
it from Jim Rohn who probably got it from somebody
else but we all overestimate what we can do in a
year and we underestimate what we can do in five
who in here in five years from now would love to
sit down with your family like I was able to do
this Christmas right after Christmas and say as
a family we have X amount of dollars that we want
to help people what do you guys want to do how
does that I don't know maybe that doesn't ring
a bell for everybody it rang a bell for me and my
wife's like oh my God I want to help kids and my
my daughter was like I want to help this there's
too much separation in our world right now who can
we help out to help Bond our communities Bond the
people become the human race my son had his idea
I'm like okay what do you want to spend go online
find a great company find somebody that's got five
star rating go come back to the table who are we
going to donate money to how does that feel what
does that do for your soul right now what does
that do for your heart right now is that bigger
than anything else but I'm telling you don't
do that until your guy until your mask is on
that's the part we all want to do who wants
to do that who wants to donate more give more
impact more right but who is I'm not saying
you shouldn't help out now if you don't donate
a million out of 10 million you won't donate
you know I mean if you won't donate a dollar
out of ten dollars you won't donate a million
out of 10 million we can do things now but be
more selfish more greedy with your time your
money and all of it right now put your focus
on you but your focus on being successful because
then in one year three year five years you get to
cut checks and make an influence make an impact
and that's what I consider being success success
isn't just the money you know I I have to tell
you and do you mind if I share I hope I hope you
don't think I'm bragging I don't tell anybody
I don't take pictures but 10 years ago 10 or 12
years ago I got invited by somebody now maybe 15
years ago I got invited to go on a private plane
I don't know I honestly don't know how long ago it
could have been 20 years ago and it was something
that was really wealthy and I was I I'm like I
came from a kid that was in a trailer park and
I was already in business I was already doing
well but nothing like that and I flew on this
plane and it was like you just drive your car to
the plane you drive right out on the tarmac I'm
in shock you get out of your car you take three
steps you walk up into the plane it takes off you
land and when you land your rental cars waiting
at the bottom of the steps I'm like holy crap
this is unbelievable there's food on the plane
there's a bathroom on the plane it's like this is
ridiculous this can't be possible and I remembered
that plane and I remember thinking myself
I'm buying one of these Someday I'm gonna buy
it after I hit certain criteria after I saved
enough after I gave enough away I'm buying
one of these and I've chartered since then
I've probably phone mostly private I don't know
10 years I don't I never talk you never hear me
talk about this look at this some of us some of
you I have a relationship with for seven to ten
years never shared this because I don't that's
why I don't want you to respect me because I got
a big house and a plane I want you to respect me
from my heart my feeling and how I got here that's
what I hope I hope I share that with you guys you
see a lot of people go on your Facebook right now
I guarantee there's somebody holding the half
a million bucks in their hand and someone else
in front of their Lamborghini and someone else
showing off their watch right you never see that
with me I wear pretty much a great t-shirt today
it's a very special day I have a greenish gray
shirt on it's a special day right here I digress
I was on that plane probably 15 18 years ago I
bought that plane a year ago but was it easy no
have I failed miserably yes have I doubted myself
absolutely have I felt like an imposter more than
you'll ever know or ever believe but it's possible
the only thing is we have to stay in the game we
have to find what drives us we have to keep moving
forward we have to say to ourselves again I know
somebody I see so many incredible people on here
I know the success you've had this isn't about you
not having success success up until now it's about
me hopefully helping you get to that next level
of success and listen I'm at a place where I don't
like yes I have a plane I have the I have a
beautiful home but I'm not flashing I don't I
drive a Ford pickup truck by the way guys if you
lived in Arizona and you saw me at a red light I
drive a white Ford F-150 every day I do not have
any other car I don't have motorcycles I don't buy
watches I have a really nice watch on my wrist
right now if you know watches it's one of the
nicest watches out there it was a present from
Tony Robbins from all the work we do together or
else I'd have a simple little watch or not wear
one at all so I'm really simple in some areas
and then I get to do the things that I want
but I wouldn't do any of those things that
I want unless I could give at the level I
want to give net last year I donated more
to charity than ever before in my life I need
to I need a break last year this year right
so that's my message for today is it's all
possible dream big but no we have to put in
the work it doesn't come by accident there's no
magical money machines you don't invent something
today and be rich tomorrow you don't put a a a a a
page up on mastermind.com on Friday and by Monday
there's a million dollars in your account it's
a process it takes time it takes effort it takes
work it takes overcoming your fear it takes being
brave it takes being courageous and at the end
of the day I've had an ulcer before as a kid I've
stressed I've gone broke I've I've been ridiculed
I felt bad about myself I felt insecure and at the
end of the day I would do it a million times over
I get to be with you amazing people and here's the
thing I know if I would have stayed and just went
into a job and worked for someone else even though
I knew I had more to give the world and I'm not
saying a job is bad I'm saying the wrong job right
still would have failed I still would have felt
like an imposter I still would have been ridiculed
all those things still would have happened but I
would have had someone else with their foot on my
head so if somebody says to me man be doing your
own thing going for that next level is scary yes
it's even scarier to think that I have to listen
live by someone else's rules for the rest of my
life think about what's scarier trying and failing
are living by someone else's rules for the rest
of your life secret number five is prioritize
your sleep with Tom bilyeu I wake up at 3am in
the morning and work hard and also I am feeling
physically healthy to do the work but after 8 am I
feel sleepy and not able to give my 100 after then
please suggest something I can do to overcome
this okay so I want to make sure that you're
getting all the sleep that you actually need so if
you're waking up at 3am but you're going to bed at
8 pm then it's fine that's seven hours of sleep
and I would say the average person probably does
fine between seven and eight hours but if you need
eight you're only getting seven that's already a
problem and if you're going to bed at 9 or 10 and
getting up at three then odds are you just aren't
getting enough sleep whenever you're feeling
tired one of two things is true you are not
getting enough sleep or high quality enough sleep
or your diet is off those two things are going to
be the things that contribute most to whether you
feel fatigued or not there's a third one which
I'll throw in which is exercise which does a great
job of addressing your mitochondria which are the
actual energy cells uh energy organelles I guess
within your cells and it is critically important
to keep those guys in shape as well just to make
sure that they can generate the cellular energy
but when you say you wake up at 3 A.M without
giving me any indication I'm checking it again
but yeah there's no indication what time you go
to bed so my gut instinct is that you're waking
up too early now if that's just naturally what
time you wake up trust me I get it I spent a very
long time just getting between five and six hours
a night and if I got six everything was great if
I got five one night in a row I was fine but if I
got five multiple nights in a row then I started
to get really tired to the point where I was once
getting my hair cut and I did one of those head
Bobs thankfully it was timed well and I didn't
end up getting a huge chunk of my hair taken out
but that was when I realized if I can't sit still
for more than five minutes without falling asleep
I don't think I'm getting enough sleep now it's
outside the scope of this video for me to get
into what I did to improve my sleep but there are
a lot of things you can do to improve your sleep
and now I'm actually sleeping more than I've ever
slept in my life because I've really got that
dialed in and I have to admit it's been awesome
to just never feel not never feel tired because
of course towards the end of the night I start
to get tired but during sort of peak productivity
hours I don't get that anymore so get all the
sleep you need I don't sleep with an alarm okay
I've run a billion dollar company I didn't set an
alarm then running a company now grew by 400 over
the last two years I don't use an alarm now so I
work 93 hours a week without using an alarm so I
don't want to hear excuses that people can't set
an alarm you just need to go to bed earlier now
if you have kids go to bed when your kids go to
bed even if it's 7 PM do whatever it takes to get
the sleep that you need you need to be a fiend
for your sleep it impacts everything else hugely
important secret number six is manipulate time
with Ed mylett if the one is bringing this new way
of thinking if the person that thinks they are the
most disqualified is able to channel that and make
somebody's life better how do they turn that into
like something concrete that they can articulate
how do they turn it into a habit like what is that
process of going from you know Neo waking up and
realizing that he can do something to actually
dodging bullets I think one of the things is the
way that we approach time this is something that
almost no one talks about anymore so I feel like
you may be behind you may actually be behind your
destiny right now like maybe you're not on Pace in
fact I think most people watching this listening
will say I am behind on achieving my destiny I'm
not exactly sure what it is but I feel like it's
slipping I feel like I'm behind so you better
figure out time differently and you can bend and
manipulate time to your advantage the most stupid
Antiquated ridiculous concept on planet Earth
today very very well maybe that a day is 24 hours
it's so stupid it's the dumbest thing ever 24-hour
days were contrived when there were no cars there
was no electricity if I wanted to get you a
message I had to write something down if I could
send it on a horseback hope you get it that's
insane never mind the internet so it used to take
hours days weeks months years to do can be done
now in a millisecond in the internet or on our
smartphones yet we measure the time the same way
that guy did that's bananas that is so stupid yet
everybody does it and so I about 25 years ago went
I'm not the most talented I'm not the smartest and
I'm really not and you've had guests on your show
with IQs maybe a hundred points higher than mine
this is the truth I know a couple of them I had
them on my show how in the world I don't come from
you know a whole track record of success right
I don't have the perfect upbringing how in the
world am I going to win I got to do things other
people aren't willing to do which I'm doing that's
the one mores and I got to fix the way I look at
time what would I need to believe about time what
would I need to believe what would the question be
and so my days now are from 6 a.m to noon that's
a day it's six hours and in that day some days
you just chill but in that day I'm gonna get the
amount of productivity Faith working out fitness
money business you name it in that day we've all
had a morning where we go I got more done this
morning I have in weeks well why can't you do that
every morning so I measure time I've compressed
and condensed time I bent it my day is 6 a.m to
noon and I'm not crazy you're crazy for thinking
it takes 24 hours just like some dude in a cave
did 300 years ago that's bananas that you still
think that way and it's unfair that people have
taught you this my second day starts at noon and
goes till 6 p.m that's day two but what the cool
thing is at the end of day one this clock goes
off about noon every day bro and goes what did
I just get done what didn't I do what do I need
to be accountable for what do I need to double my
efforts just like you do at the end of most days
right and then the next day is 6 p.m to midnight
and some of those are just fun days Sundays I
chill right but some days they're really super
productive what I've done now is I have changed
a manipulated time I now get 21 days a week
back that up over a month I'm gonna kick your
butt stack it up over a year your toast stack
it up over five years my entire life is different
than it would have been otherwise and if you do
this for about 90 of your traditional days that
you think are you will come back to me and go
that profoundly impacted my life and here's the
other thing that happens the world responds to
you differently when you value your time like that
what is precious is valuable that's why a diamond
or this watch is way more expensive than the piece
of paper that's written down there because it's
more scarce when your time when you interact with
the world is slightly more scarce they respond to
you as if you're more valuable so you get more
accountability more productivity more fun more
joy and the world flips its response to you all of
a sudden you become more valuable and precious to
people when your time is different and you'll get
thousands more days in your life and live a much
more Blissful and happy life than the person only
gets 24 hours and secret number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is work on
yourself with sad Guru the most important thing
is to work upon yourself what does it mean by
saying working upon yourself physically just set
up small goals for yourself for the next few weeks
that are there suppose you're 18 for the last 30
years when the first time when you became 18 if
you did bend down how far would you go at that
time maybe it went all all the way to the floor
today maybe it's like this just see if you can
go six inches more when you're 18 years of age how
quickly you went up a staircase today how you are
applauding up the staircase see if you can improve
it by 10 20 20 Improvement in the next two weeks
just check your picture when you are 18 or below
how you would stand how straight you were and now
if you become like this straighten yourself up a
little bit look further back what kind of smile
you had when you were six eight ten years of age
see if you can get 50 of that back on your face
all the time not by simply grinning a plastic
smile but bring that magic back into you if you
cannot do anything fantastic at least you must
be a pleasant piece of Life on this planet this
is something that you owe to yourself and to
everybody who lives around you this you must
do so set up your own kind of goals and see it's
not difficult I'm telling you just needs little
attention right now people think they're carrying
the world on their head no no just in case you are
in shirazasana right now and you take a picture
and turn it around it looks like you're carrying
the planet on your head but that's not the truth
whether or you're on your feet or on your head
planet is scaring you and it's spinning by itself
day and night is happening by itself seasons are
changing by itself Sun comes and goes by itself
really there's nothing to do these two weeks
are for time for you to realize everything that is
significant in the universe is happening by itself
it's for you to sit here and enjoy the Bounty of
life just make use of this do not act like you are
running the whole planet or you are running the
whole universe for that matter you are not it is
happening by itself you're a tiny little creature
who is here for a little bit of time don't make so
much fuss about it to handle a few years of life
do not make such a big fuss these few weeks you
must come out as a more pleasant and wonderful
human being this is the greatest thing you can
do to yourself if you sit here this person is a
pleasant experience for you if you are a pleasant
experience for yourself everybody else will also
experience this person as a pleasant experience
what great things you will do or not do that is
subject to various realities nobody can fix it
hundred percent you must understand our actions
are largely determined by the times in which we
exist suppose you were here five thousand years
ago five thousand years ago if you were here and
this door virus came to you you didn't have to
do any social distancing because anyway there was
nobody around you even if you wanted to infect you
couldn't find a person so you need to understand
what we are doing our actions and what we do and
do not do is the times in which we exist if you
are here five thousand years ago you would not
be writing software you would be doing something
else you would not be doing all the things that
you're doing today don't think you are doing it
it is the times in the times the times that we
are in has its own weather some smooth weather
some rough weather if you learn to ride this
weather gracefully then people say you're a
success if you create a problem about every little
fluctuation that happens then you become a failure
in your life if you were a wave surfer you've
seen people surfing on the waves what is his
his dream he would like to have a tsunami the
dream in a surfer's mind is a tsunami a hundred
foot tall wave riding it that would be the dream
if you know how to ride it even the tsunami is a
wonderful thing so right now virus it is not going
by itself it is not flying by itself and getting
you it needs us to get somewhere it's for us to
decide whether it goes somewhere or it doesn't go
somewhere it's our business to see that it doesn't
go anywhere it should not come to you in case it
did happen that it come to you you must ensure
it does not go to anybody else 100 because this
is the time to show who you are as a generation
of people this is a generational issue because no
more it's a national issue this is not an issue
of a caste Creed religion no or race virus is
quite very even-handed it doesn't matter what's
your race what's your religion what's your Caster
Creed indiscriminately it is going to people
initially people thought it will only get the
Chinese well now everybody is realizing virus is
not just interested in Chinese people it is okay
with anybody quite indiscriminate so this is a
generational challenge in these challenging times
will you ride this wave successfully or will you
be crushed by this can only be determined by how
responsibly you respond to this whole thing with
how much sense or will we do something senseless
and make this into a massive disaster right now
in India and in most parts of the world except
unfortunately in a few countries a lot of people
don't understand what is the threshold anymore if
you go to an Indian temple there will be one foot
high threshold it will be little wide if you are
not physically fit you will little struggle over
that but those who are fit very effortlessly they
will cross this threshold and go right now it's
only a threshold to cross but if we feed it with
irresponsibility this threshold has the potential
to become a huge mountain that we cannot cross
it needs responsible behavior and responsible
action what does responsible mean normally most
human beings are in a state of compulsive reaction
responsible action means you consciously respond
you consciously respond to what is in front of you
not compulsively behaved saying that this is the
way I will do things conscious response because
responsibility means it's just your ability to
respond this is the most important thing in
your life that you have retained your ability
to respond to whatever comes our way because
what comes our way is not determined by us
to some extent we can decide what comes our way
largely what comes our way is not determined by
us the world decides but whatever comes our way
what we make out of it is 100 hours this is the
time to show who we are what are we made of Are
We human beings or are we just one more compulsive
instinctive creature this is what is being tested
right now for you this is an evolutionary test for
you see it is not only for a monkey that some itch
in the body may happen even for you it happens if
it happens you handle it a lot of people are there
you don't anything when people are not there you
do it like this this is conscious response this
is an evolutionary test for you you have to prove
that you have become a Human Being Human Being
means one who knows how to be this is a time
for you to show you know how to be bad people are
cooped up together for long hours people who you
claimed that you love immensely seven days getting
very difficult for a lot of people you must
address this also why has it become so difficult
why is it so difficult to be with people simply
because we have formed strong opinions and ideas
about everybody including ourselves this is an
important thing that you have to do if you have to
live here as a conscious human being that is you
have no opinions of any sort strong opinions means
you have concluded about everything in the world
there's nothing to live here for when you have
made conclusions about everybody and everything
including yourself this means you have destroyed
all possibilities of life life is a possibility
but between the possibility and reality there
is a distance in your life will you walk the
distance or not do you have the courage and the
commitment to walk the distance or no this is all
the question is about your life I hope you answer
this question positively because you can address
this in so many ways this happened after the
singing disaster I'm saying after the classical
music concert happened in shankaran pillai's home
she gave up classical music because of the comment
that he gave then after three days it was three
days classical music next three days nothing to
do so she spent some time in front of the mirror
she looked at herself when she got married how she
looked and today how she's looking because of the
planetary influence she was taking the shape of
the globe so she stood in front of the mirror
in the bedroom younger and pillai was sitting
on the bed reading something she said you know
how I have become how I used to be every year
my size is going up clothing size I'm looking
ugly look at my face everything is sagging my
complexion is gone I have bags under my eyes
this damn Planet it could have been slim some
I just kept reading dude please say something say
something nice say something that's good about me
I'm completely depressed looking at myself
in the mirror say something nice something
that's good about me looked up and said well your
vision is perfect something is good about you so
this is not a time to go about picking faults
in each other or even in yourself you just see
how every week you can be at least 10 percent
better physically 10 better mentally ten percent
better emotionally 10 better Behavior wise 10
better relationship wise 10 better one week ten
percent thirty percent increase in everything you
will be quite a fantastic human being believe me
and one of the things that will help you to do the
work to create the things that you want in your
life is it will help you if you train your mind to
start spotting evidence as you're doing the work
as you're going through your day it will help you
if you train your mind to start scanning the world
and spotting evidence that yes indeed the world is
sending you positive signals that things are going
to work out now why is it important to train your
mind to help you get what you want well the reason
why is because if you get into a negative mindset
if you start thinking this business is never going
to work why even bother I'm never going to meet
anybody it's nothing but losers out there look at
all these idiots on hinge why the hell should
I keep doing this if you allow your mind to
start to rest in a pessimistic negative protective
scared and doubtful stance your mind will continue
to show you reasons why there's nobody on hinged
worth talking to your mind will continue to show
you all the reasons why you will never make it in
business your mind will continue to show you all
the reasons why you're never going to lose that
weight and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend Corinne Crabtree always talks about that
transformational moment and when your mind goes
negative your mind starts to scan the world and
will show you more reasons to stop and the power
of training your mind to spot positive signs is
very simple the power is that your mind will start
to show you reasons to keep going your mind will
help you take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered just like
you woke up today on a Tuesday and it was February
22nd 2022 and those numbers are lining up and that
makes you in your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that [__] only
happens like once in my lifetime those numbers
are going to line up like that today is a really
cool day let's go do something with this you could
create that kind of attitude every single freaking
day of your life you could if you train your mind
and if you start taking action and training your
mind is the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read the high
five habit one of the things that I talk about a
lot is every single day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it could be a
stone it could be a leaf it could be a cloud
it could be a shape in your coffee hey Chris
if we've got anything around here that looks like
a heart hand it to me and the reason why I love
telling you to start playing a game with yourself
well you start your day going mind brain show me
some heart oh what is this come here dog treat
oh my God it's a dog treat look at this guys
what shape is that that right there is a harp
there we go check that out if you say brain mind
show me a heart today guess what's gonna happen
that damn dog biscuit it's gonna show it's gonna
you're gonna be like there's a heart you're gonna
look out at the sky and you're gonna see a heart
shape oh right there in the mountains there's a
heart shape in the mountains in southern Vermont
you're going to see it in the clouds what you're
doing when you tell your mind what's important to
you is you're telling your mind and the filter
in your brain to change in real time and allow
into your consciousness what's important to you
and if you want to see hearts by God those damn
dog treats are going to start looking like
hearts everybody that's how you train your
mind it's freaking incredible and if you want to
see evidence of this follow me on social media
if you follow me Mel Robbins on social media you
will see every day I am reposting your stories of
finding heart shapes around the world now why is
this important well it's important because it's
a simple way to prove to you that your mind
changes in real time that if you get serious
about becoming more positive and optimistic and
encouraging of yourself if you get serious about
saying this I don't want to see all the reasons
why I'm unhappy I don't want to see everybody
else in the world that's launched a business or
that's lost weight and is healthy or that has a
really good marriage or relationship and I don't
want to see that and and have my mind process it
as evidence that it's never going gonna happen
for me I want my mind to reprogram itself and
see other people's businesses and see other
people getting healthy and see other people
in relationships and I want my mind to say yeah if
they can do it I can do it that's evidence if that
person can get healthy so can I if that person can
find somebody on hinge so can I if that person can
reconcile with their child so can I other people
can become evidence that you can have it too right
now your mind is so [__] up from your past
that when you see what other people have and
you don't have it you can't actually translate it
through a negative mind and and see that that's
evidence that you're going to win you see it like
oh somebody already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your mind
to is that you have the power to train your mind
to filter the world differently just like
you woke up and you saw the date today 2
22 22 and your brain saw that was like whoa
this is a once in a lifetime day everybody
you're never going to have another
day that lines up like this ever
what are you gonna do with this day your mind
already interpreted this as wow something
cool could happen and if you tell yourself
something amazing is going to happen today
something will because you're going to be looking
for it I swear to God something will something
will if you want to see the good all around you
you got to tell your mind you want to see the good
and this just isn't a bunch of horsesh everybody
this isn't toxic positivity there is a filter in
your brain called the reticular activating system
the reticular activating system I call it the RAS
I like to think about it like a giant hair
net on your head and this Ras sits over your
brain I'm probably getting this wrong I'm not
a neuroscientist I could give about getting it
right I just need you to know the basics here
so that you can apply it to your life okay you
don't need a PhD to use the science that super
smart people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's what
I'm here for in your life I'm here to translate
this stuff into simple believable and actionable
things that you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and apply it
to your normal person's everyday life to help you
change from the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is you have
a whole system in your body that you can train and
change and one of those things that you can train
and change that is impacted by that real that word
you're hearing a lot of neuroplasticity that just
means that things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new things for as
long as you're alive as long as you're breathing
everybody you got a chance to change the way that
you think as long as you are breathing you got
a chance to change from the inside out how you
experience your life as long as you are still here
watching me people you got a chance to create a
new experience in your life and one of the things
that helps a lot is understanding that right now
all of the bullsh from your past has jammed the
filter in your mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding your ability
to look at the world around you and see hearts
remember this dog treat hearts look at that
there's a heart right there it dawned on me that
sometimes we don't have the right
frames when we're doing something
and we don't give things the right meanings
and let me explain what I mean to you by that
when we start something new I think sometimes
we forget that anything that is new to our brain
may be exciting and may release dopamine
the neurochemical that he knows the reward
neurochemical and uh we feel good because we've
taken on this new Endeavor whether it's a new
language whether it's retraining our brain whether
it's um starting to exercise or eating better or
committing to doing something that's of
benefit to us or even stopping something
now the very nature of how our brain works is
that patterns that have been repeated over you
know months and years are the dominant patterns in
our brain and therefore it's easier for our brain
to activate and follow through to completion
on those patterns it's like having a you know
highway system that's been built it's easy for
the cars to go faster on the highway system well
the same thing is true with our brain and the
neural networks and Pathways so the pathways
are the easiest for the chemicals to travel
across and release the neurochemicals you know
that make us feel good or make us feel fearful
or make us feel apprehensive or doubtful Etc
are the ones that are the easiest for our brain
to activate and follow through on okay part one
so that means that a new pattern meaning stopping
something or starting something requires a little
bit more of the brain's energy and the Brain wants
to conserve energy so what is our brain naturally
going to do and the answer is it's going to resist
why because it wants to preserve the energy that
may be required in case there's a saber-toothed
tiger that comes around from you know the the
woods to try and kill you so we're in this energy
conservation mindset without even knowing it our
biology is geared towards doing things that are
easy for us not things that require energy right
glucose so why am I sharing this with you well as
you're you know on your journey of brain training
upgrading your Knowledge and Skills taking
actions probably different actions that you
are taking to achieve the results that you want
more and better results from of um it requires
you accessing higher cortical functions and a
higher level of awareness especially pay close
attention especially when you feel resistance now
I came out here I still have my workout gloves on
because as I was doing uh some ab work as I was
doing you know some bench press and flies for my
chest one of the things that dawned on me is most
people do things that they are comfortable doing
but in order to get stronger from a cardiovascular
perspective you have to challenge yourself mix up
your routines you've got to go a little bit longer
a little bit harder you know on the days that you
want to expand your capabilities so in the world
of uh you know doing weights for strength training
or building muscle there's certain techniques
to use in certain strategies use including rest
right muscles build built in the rest phase so
let me explain what I'm talking about I think
you know where I'm going with this when I let's
say do a bench press or fly or I walk up a hill
the place where it's the hardest where
there's resistance where I want to quit
and stop and I'm breathing heavier I just can't
do another rep that's the point of the growth
and the more you practice at that place
right the resistance the point of I want
to quit I can't do it anymore that is how
you expand your capacity resistance happens
when you're at the edges of Your Capacity now it
could be mental edges emotional edges physical
edges Financial edges and how does it show up
it shows up as stress right stress so stress
happens when your current capacity let me repeat
stress happens when your current capacity exceeds
the demand your current capacity exceeds the
demand so how do you increase demand I'm sorry how
do you increase capacity well you feel the edges
and go one more you feel the tension and keep
doing it you feel the desire to quit but then you
do as much as you can and as you do as much as you
can you get mentally stronger physically stronger
emotionally stronger so when I feel like let's say
quitting I just say just a little bit more when
I don't feel like it I say I know but just do
a little bit why because I want to override my
natural and your natural propensity to want to
quit to want to stop it's natural but I don't want
to be natural I want to be Supernatural I don't
want to be ordinary I want to be extraordinary
and that's that little extra does that make sense
so as you're training your brain as you have
videos to watch to upgrade your Knowledge and
Skills as you have events to attend you know
to to connect to to listen to learn to expand
if you catch yourself thinking or feeling I don't
feel like it I'm too tired not today tomorrow
that's the language okay that the brain uses the
rationalizations the rational lies that your brain
my brain everybody's brain uses to keep you in
your comfort zone well guess what everything you
want financially in your relationship health-wise
is just outside your comfort zone if you keep
challenging and expanding your mental emotional
physical spiritual Financial Comfort zones you
expand as a human being and you start fulfilling
more of your potential than standing on the edge
of it hoping and praying and wishing that you can
have greater better results when it comes to an
affirmation uh affirmations can be powerful uh and
for some people they're not and a lot of people
say well you know if the the affirmation is so
powerful how come I'm not experiencing the effect
the what scientists tell us is the average human
speaks to themselves consciously or unconsciously
we have thoughts spinning around in our brain
about 60 to 80 000 thoughts per day some of those
thoughts are the words to the songs and they are
the affirmations uh neuroscientist Andrew nurburg
tells us Newberg is his name I'm sorry and um in
his work that that a single word a single word
has the power to to change the genes that creates
stress or relieve stress in our lives he's telling
us that that something within us has the ability
to shift to the very core of our expression so
we know that words are are powerful the key to a
successful affirmation is that we must communicate
with the subconscious part of our of our mind
number one number two we must communicate in the
language that the subconscious recognizes
and this is where uh you know you can say
I had a friend of mine when I was working in the
corporations that had affirmations all over his
office all over his computer screen they were on
little Post-it notes in the car we would carpool
in you know my Perfect Mate is manifesting for
me now my Perfect Mate is manifesting for me now
that was his affirmation and I said do you say
these things he goes oh man I see him about a
million times a day I said did they work for you
he says Nah you know these these things don't
work and I said why do you think they don't work
and he said look at me he says I'm an engineer
I'm a slob he said I I wear the same clothes to
work three out of five days during the week you
know and and the the bottom line by the time he
finished describing himself to me even he didn't
believe that he was worthy of his Perfect Mate
manifesting for him now so he was saying the words
but he was not there was the the underlying
emotion and what he was actually feeding into his
his system was counter to what those words were
saying so it's it's not enough to say the words
when we go into our most ancient and cherished
spiritual Traditions those words are what become
the prayers and for many people I have and I
know you've heard this as well a lot of people
feel that prayer is broken that the world doesn't
work today the way it worked in biblical times
that we have lost our power and that we
have no ability to communicate with a
greater power with god with the forces
around us and it's largely because
the secrets the Deep truth of our relationship
the fundamental physics of our relationship to
our world uh have been minced and parceled and in
many cases deleted from the texts leaving us with
a sense that we are essentially powerless beings
and if you are powerless then you are a victim
and if you're a victim you need a savior and that
savior is coming to us on a silver plate in terms
of technology in terms of political leaders
I will save you if you just do these things
and this is why I say I think one of the most the
most powerful acts and the most radical act we can
do is to think for ourselves uh original thinking
based upon the Deep truth of our relationship to
our bodies and the Earth not based upon the false
assumptions of obsolete science that permeate our
academic world right now it's one of the reasons
I left Academia it's one of the reasons many of my
colleagues who are in this genre who are very well
respected scientists have left Academia because
they were not allowed to share with students
and in their writings and their papers what
they had found in their research that reflects a
very different reality now for me it's it's a uh
it's good news it's a beautiful message of Hope
and possibility as a sovereign biological being
for a system that's based on centralized power
and control it's probably the worst news they
could imagine because it means we don't need the
centralized power and control I think ultimately
we're all better off by embracing our own power
because it frees us from the fear of a changing
world and we all know our world my world is
changing your world is changing nor has it ever
faster than we can document it in our classrooms
and textbooks but the change isn't necessarily bad
until we compare it to what we've known in the
past and this is where the fear comes in so the
the new discoveries helping us to understand we
are part of rather than separate from our world
and this is this is where the affirmations come
in so in um I was at the CERN super conducting
super collider in Geneva Switzerland where
the the physics experiments that are revealing
what happened moments after our universe began
they recreate the beginning of our universe
and then they're able to document what happened
then to create the laws of physics that we are
experiencing that we're living under right now and
what they announced in 2012 is that there is in
fact a field an intelligent field of energy it's
a subtle energy that underlies all of creation
um before then it was a metaphor or a lot of
people felt like it was a new age concept you
know we are all one everything is is connected
or an indigenous you know a lot of indigenous
Elders talk about this here's here's where they
got stuck and I've gone to Scientific conferences
where they'll take their hands and they'll say oh
yeah there's that's that's no longer controversial
there is a field there's a field out there that
connects all things and their hands go like this
there's a field out there that connects all things
because subconsciously they're still saying we're
separate from that field right but here's what
the science is showing us and this this was a
game changer for me uh just a mind blower that
every atom in every molecule and every cell of our
bodies in this very instant so it's not like it's
about to happen that's it's happening right now
every atom is constantly emerging and collapsing
into that field and what that says to us is that
we are the field it's not the fields out there we
literally are wrinkles we are disturbances in this
field this this body that is held in place by a
conscious awareness as long as I'm breathing on
this Earth I am a disturbance I'm a localized
Wrinkle in that field and what that means
is that if I want to bring about change in my
world I don't have to force a change out there
I become that change and as I have become that
change the field is now reflecting what it is
because I'm part of the field so it's a subtle but
it's a very powerful way a very different way of
thinking you're not you're not imposing change
on the world around you you are becoming the
change so you're becoming the abundance you're
becoming uh the love the Gratitude the care
uh the healing you're becoming those things
and that is very different we're conditioned
to ask for them to plead for them because we're
led to feel powerless in our lives when in fact
there are modalities of ancient prayer that were
edited from the the religious texts in the fourth
Century by the church they took they took out the
information helping us to understand that this
this deep relationship leaving us powerless and
and affirmations are essentially a form of Prayer
or prayer is a form of affirmation however you
want to look at it where we are communicating
and I want to be really clear it's not about
control it's not about manipulation it's not about
imposing our will it's about participating in the
way that this field unfolds and expresses in in
our lives and when you really begin to get that
shift it's it's still and it's powerful it's not
making something happen out there and that
means you can't blame what's out there for your
experiences I I come from a very dysfunctional
broken family and I had to make a choice early in
life as to whether or not I would and Community uh
as to whether or not I would allow that to Define
my my experience to Define my existence other
people around me had the same experience and
they made very different choices they today
continue to blame their environment their
parents their family their upbringing for the
sad and unfortunate things in their lives and
and that's a path it's not right wrong good or
bad but we have a choice to make another path
and when we begin as a scientist beginning to
understand these relationships gave me the reason
to think differently and they'll also give me the
reason to test in my life if those thoughts are
really true or not what works and what doesn't
if you think that your thoughts have something
to do with your future just from a theoretical
standpoint that your thoughts Create Your Destiny
and you think sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day and ninety percent of those thoughts
are the same thoughts as the day before well then
your life isn't going to change very much as long
as you're thinking the same way and those those
same thoughts lead to the same choices the same
choices lead to the same behaviors the same
behaviors create the exact same experiences
and we anticipate the same feelings or emotions
from those experiences and those emotions are
the payoff that drive our very same thoughts
while our biology our neural circuitry our
neurochemistry our hormones and even our gene
expression will be equal to how we think how we
act and how we feel and how we think how we act
and how we feel is called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality that's
it so the present personality who's listening
to this show has created the present personal
reality called their life so if you can latch
on to this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to change
your personality which means you better start
thinking about what you've been thinking about
and changing it you begin to be become conscious
of your unconscious actions or habits or behaviors
and modify them and then we have to begin to look
at the emotions that we live by every single day
keep us connected to the past and decide do these
emotions belong in our future so most people are
trying to create a new personal reality as
the same personality and it doesn't work
you literally have to become someone else so the
principle of Neuroscience says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together you keep thinking
the same way making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same experiences
that stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns all for the familiar feeling
called you and you do that for 10 years on end
you're going to begin to hardwire certain patterns
in your brain that becomes your identity and by
the time we're 35 years old it kind of becomes
fixed right and psychology used to say that you
can't change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain that is
the habit of ourselves it's a we're 95 percent
of the time running a series of programs so then
sitting and doing the work had we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so the moment
you decide to do something differently or make a
new choice but most people don't want to face is
that discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of predictability
the that that that unknown is what people are
afraid of because they'd rather live in guilt
at least they can predict who they're going to
be then take a chance in possibility so when a
person begins to understand this and you say
well how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and you say
why 35 years because 35 years ago I had this one
event well the stronger the emotion you feel from
the reaction from that event the more altered you
feel inside of you the more the brain Narrows its
focus and freezes the image and takes a snapshot
and that's called a memory right so then forget
the memory just overcome the emotion because
it's the emotion that keeps you anchored to the
past so that sounds really good theoretically
but when you step out into that unknown into
that void the body really is in a habit and
what a habit is when the body becomes the mind or
if you're thinking about that past event and it's
producing an emotion well you need an image and
a feeling to start the conditioning process so
the body's either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the predictable future
because it wakes up every single day and runs
through the same series of routine actions so
the present moment then becomes the unknown when
people start feeling that discomfort today they
rather get on their cell phone and call someone
or get up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse themselves
they return back into that familiar feeling
because the body's actually telling the brain
The Habit is when the body becomes the mind so
the body stepping out into the unknown and says
ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd rather feel unhappy
then be in this this conference so then at least
then when they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step out in
the unknown and the body starts influencing the
mind saying you can start tomorrow you're too
busy it's your mother's fault you know it's
your culture's fault I don't have enough money
this isn't going to work those are the programs
in there that are standing in the way between
you and your future so then nerve cells that
no longer fire together no longer wire together
so the act of observing those states of Mind and
Body means you're no longer the program you're the
Consciousness observing that program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar with so as
you become familiar with those thoughts you become
conscious of how you speak you become aware of
how you act you notice how you're feeling the more
conscious you become of those unconscious programs
the less unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have a great
meditation and get up and get on the freeway and
get in traffic and getting stressed you just
return back to the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of Mind
and Body the entire day and if you can
get ready because something different or unusual
is going to begin to happen in your life and it
will come as a coincidence or synchronicity
and that's breadcrumbs from the Divine saying
you're on the path just keep doing it there'll be
another one just keep staying in that energy and
so teaching people then to understand that there's
a formula that we now know that if you apply that
formula you'll begin to see those changes and now
as people are doing it more and more effectively
the results are going up as well we just had
Bond University they just took a whole bunch
of my brain scans from 10 years ago huge clinical
study a lot of analysis and and they're Blown Away
by the speed in which the community can change
brain or hard coherence they they know how to
do it it's not something that's that's separate
from them they've practiced it enough times that
they they now know how to do it so what's the
significance of that well really simple in your
life if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and circumstances
you're returning back to the old self so you got
to stay conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the future then
you're left with the memories of the past and you
will be predictable in your life so Crossing that
River of change from the old self to the new self
there's a neurological a biological chemical
hormonal a genetic death of the old self but
if you teach people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves they'll keep
going so there's enough evidence to encourage
people and you can't tell me you're too old to
do this work you can't tell me you're too sick to
do this work you can't tell me you had a turbulent
past or or that you're too overweight or too
underweight or too out of shape or you can't even
tell me that you've never meditated before in fact
some of our greatest scans are people who just
have never meditated before that we're not trying
to do anything they just follow instructions so
our community now is beginning to understand that
it is possible and they go all in not 50 and not
60 and we do a week-long event we got a thousand
people or 1500 people and they are all in and that
when they start getting Beyond themselves that
first day or second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts to happen
then I have no idea I can't predict what's going
to happen next and it's usually pretty pretty
exciting you want to be a professional baseball
player is that right yeah but then you got an
injury I did similar to me so you never made it to
the big leagues or did you play minor league I did
yeah and I played division one college baseball
too yeah I like every guy like you and I talked
about this last time it's always our injuries that
ended our careers I probably it probably put me
into a premature place where I was going anyways I
don't know you aren't going to be in The Bigs for
I wasn't I played enough baseball all the guys who
ended up in the big leagues to know my limitations
yeah so like anything in life things happen for
you not to you that injury happened for me it
certainly didn't seem like it at the time but
it got me out of that and into something like what
we're talking about now that completely changed my
life so yeah but yeah I want to be an athlete for
sure all my life all your life that was my mask
and then when it exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like who am I right yes lost
yeah like a lot you and I were just talking before
we went on yeah you know our professional athlete
friends were their career changes I went into a
like anybody like whatever your dream is when the
first one ends it doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage it ends it
was a dream right or a business venture or a sport
I went into a pretty good depression and uh and
how old were you at the time 21 22 and I ended up
you know it's because people always see the after
like the house or whatever houses or whatever the
material things are but I ended up bad man I ended
up depressed I ended up moving back at home with
my parents I was living in the city I remember I
was living in this sleeping in the same bed I grew
up in with the same teddy bear the same posters
like going back in time like six years on back
where I was totally unemployed and uh couldn't
find work didn't have the motivation to get up
and find a job just sort of eating out of their
fridge and laying around all day so that's where I
was many many years ago after base Poland when you
realize things in your life happen for you truly
especially in hindsight everybody knows it in
hindsight right if you look back at any disaster
tragedy most people look back five ten years they
think that happened for me that was actually a
good thing and so I was unemployed I couldn't
find a job and my old man my dad was the best
dad role model he could ever have in your life
hard-working man good man it's better man than me
has more Integrity than me he's the best man I've
ever known but when I was growing up my dad had
a drinking problem and so my dad had gotten sober
recently and he was going to these meetings and
he comes home from one of his meetings and says
there's a guy at my meeting who can get you a
job that's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids doesn't pay
anything at six bucks an hour but you're gonna
get this damn job so show up there tomorrow
morning 8 A.M ask for Tim so I walked I drive
down there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would alter
my entire life that was the most significant
thing that happened to me and so I walk in there
I said I'm Ed mylette I'm here for the job you're
like what job I'm like I don't know just my dad
told me to show up here yeah I need to ask for
Tim they're like we have no idea who the hell
Tim is what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're like so you
showed up for a job that you don't know what it is
and you don't know who it is it's hiring you I'm
like here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm like
oh dude yeah we know that too and so they bring
me to the guy and he says uh you're hired let's go
look literally shakes my hand and you're hired and
he introduces me to these eight boys that were my
boys they were seven eight and nine years old and
basically I lived with these boys these precious
boys and we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were all molested
by family where parents were in prison and so they
had no family and so my whole life changed all
of a sudden these became on this 22 year old guy
these guys become my sons wow and I did holidays
with them I did birthdays with them I lived with
them literally in a home or like a literally
McKinley is a massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes that live
in individual like Cottages like a foster care
facility massive though really yep all boys it's
in San Dimas here and um wow it just altered my
life man because I I'd been an athlete had a huge
ego had that mask I wanted to compete I wanted to
win I wanted attention I wanted recognition first
time literally in my life I went well I I love
helping people I love making a difference and my
boys were just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time and I have
those eyes too you have them I think sometimes
kids who grow up with some dysfunction they just
have different eyes yeah they just have these eyes
that are these boys all were different but they
had that same eyes they just like man love me
believe in me you know care about me and I had
those eyes because I grew up in an alcoholic
family and my whole life changed I just went wow
I love I actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know that
because everything was you're great you're great
you know what it is when you're an athlete right
everything's about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud all of a sudden I was in a
stud and all of a sudden it wasn't about me it was
about these 10 boys that ended up being 10 of them
and it just altered my life man and so after that
I ran into the financial business that I ended
up in but I would have completely flunked out
of that Financial business had I not been with my
boys for those years and I was there for two years
two years yeah man like eight hours a day type of
thing or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. I I think
about I'm not kidding you I think about my boys
and my experience there two of them are still very
close with me uh every day there's a moment where
I reflect on that it altered me completely like
what I wanted to do I always wanted to be famous
and Rich and successful and now I just wanted to
serve yeah I wanted to help the little that I find
out I could get rich and famous and all that other
stuff I thought I wanted through serving people
see this line that's called The Terror barrier
yeah jumping at you isn't it and on the other side
of the terror barrier is something we call Freedom
and you know very few people get through
that Terror barrier it's rather sad freedom
is available to everyone there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to live
see why don't they why don't they they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know now I'm
going to show you why people experience buyer's
remorse when they buy something they really want
and then they back away or they go to move and
they don't they go to change jobs and they don't
they go to move to another city and they don't
why fear causes them to stay where they are
here's the individual the X represents
the unknown factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember
we said we had the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts that
are in harmony with the Paradigm now here's
an important point the Paradigm controls the
vibration of this thing we call our body our
body is a molecular instrument that's really
what it is it's a mass of molecules and a very
high speed of vibration the vibration that the
body is in on a conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or they feel
that way what they're really doing is describing
the vibration they're in now they choose
thoughts that harmonize with the vibration
they're in so they feel comfortable they may
not like the results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look here those
people are getting X-Type results and they don't
like it do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are locked up
you know Paradigm is like keeping a person in
a prison only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison to walk out into Freedom
anytime they want and they don't they keep
getting the same results over and over and
over again they're in bondage now let's go
ahead here's the same person X-Type conditioning
X-Type vibration the power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from Left Field
above bone in comes a y-type idea what is the
y-type idea the y-type idea represents anything
that you might want to do that you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change jobs
sell the house buy the farm whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask
the guy to go to lunch go make the sale
buy what you want go where you want to go that's
the why idea but as long as the why ideas just
in the conscious mind it's just going to be an
intellectual exercise it's never going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's when
everything goes haywire here we are here same
person okay the power Flows In and what do
they do they got the y-type idea now for some
strange reason they know that they've got to get
emotionally involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's going to
happen but clearly understand this your central
nervous system is the most complex electrical
system in the universe the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the electrical
system in a supercomputer look like a toy now
the second you take the idea from your intellect
and impress it upon the subject of mine that's
when all hell breaks loose because the body moves
in to an extra XY vibration it's not in the X
vibration not the one that we're comfortable with
may not like the results but we're comfortable no
on a conscious level everything's going crazy
on a conscious level we experience doubt the
doubt turns into an emotion called fear and that
fear is expressed through the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and they
bounce off it and right back into bondage
and they're so relieved to get back there
they're back where they're comfortable they've
canceled the sale they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that they
don't like at least they're comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going to
grow you're going to hit that Terror barrier
see the terror barrier is going Beyond where
you're at going to a new level I'm going to
tell you something when I set a goal if if it
doesn't scare and excite me at the same time
I know I'm going in the wrong direction
now I also understand that my Paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce back to
where I was it doesn't want me to move ahead
I don't want to live there ice lived there
for the first 26 years of my life and for
the last 50 I've had a phenomenal life and
it just keeps getting better and I want
you to do the same thing understand what
I've just said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y idea that
moved their body into a different vibration on a
conscious level they're experiencing some crazy
stuff they start to doubt their ability we'll
never be able to pay for it they experience
fear the fear expresses itself as anxiety
and dang you bounce off that Terror barrier and
you're right back oh I might not be earning much
here but I know what it is I I would love to move
there but I'm comfortable here I think I'll just
stay here these people are acting like they have
a contract to live forever and they don't you know
what to do say I'm going to get rid of all that
I understand it's there but I don't want any part
of it and I'm going to go crashing right through
that Terror barrier now does that get rid of the
X energy no that's energy is still there you see
but at least you're over into Freedom you made
the move you did it and if you continue to feed
the right information into your mind keep feeding
that y idea keep getting emotionally involved in
the Y idea you're there you're on the road keep
doing that you're going to find that the Paradigm
is going to change and it'll just all go away
and you know you're living in Freedom
you're living where you want to live
fires remorse is when you cancel a sale buyer's
remorse is when you stop just before you buy
what you really want before you go for the thing
that's going to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's not
starting the business of your dreams it's
not stepping out and betting on yourself that's
a terror barrier that's causing that and if you
don't learn to go through the terror barrier I'm
going to tell you something you're going to stay
right where you are for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be what did Joseph
Campbell say so true they cave you fear to enter
holds the treasure you seek discipline is your
missing ingredient you've got the heart you've
got the care you've got the desire to serve you
know you could be doing more you want to do it
for the right reasons you're not just here to
make money you're here to have an impact in
the grow and do amazing things you know you
can do amazing things what's missing discipline
there's just a lack of follow-through it's the
constant start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop and for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing somebody
who's got so much talent and so much potential and
so much of a heart and just seeing them not win
because they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent enough work
that you're motivated and inspired and then and
then you're not anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me the only
one of the only reasons why I'm here making these
videos and you're watching and I've had any you
know success in social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making videos one of
the things I love sharing is my journey of YouTube
because I was not an overnight success story every
month almost I'll post my socials of how I grew
month over month year over year on YouTube and in
the first five years I had 7 000 subscribers or
so five years in five years in of making content
7 000 subscribers a lot of you already ahead of
that a lot of you could get there a lot faster
than me you know how do you keep going when you're
not getting traction when in year one you have a
hundred subscribers I I just had the discipline
to keep making content to keep following through
in 12 000 videos later here we are and and
people can get there faster you don't have to be
as slow as me you know I took I took a long
time and I had a lot of issues I was shy and
insecure and introverted and felt like you had
to be you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limiting beliefs
all sorts of issues and you can get there a
lot faster than me but it still requires a
discipline to follow through and do it and
I really think it's one of the only things
that saved me I remember sitting down at a
um Florida outlet mall and I was sitting there
with uh with a friend and Nina was going shopping
and uh we spent half an hour at a at a Starbucks
there while she was shopping and he said I'm gonna
be the next garyvee of my industry it was in
music I'm going to be the next garyvee in music
and uh You're Gonna Keep doing your thing like
let's you know let's let's keep in touch and see
how we do and how we grow and he posted you know
three or four years later on his Instagram and he
said you know three or four years three or four
years ago I met Evan Carmichael at this Outlet
Mall in Florida they had our picture as the as
the host and I told him I was going to be the next
garyvee for music and he's gonna do keep doing
his thing and and Evan went on and did his thing
and I stopped I didn't have the success that I
said I was gonna have and here's the thing this
guy has way more Talent than I do and he's a super
talented in music and just better camera presence
more energy uh more his videos just look better
way more attention to detail he had all of this
stuff and and like a warm amazing human who cares
and wants to serve and wants to see musicians
make money and turn their art into something
amazing right like he had all of this stuff
all of it the only thing he lack was discipline
and he didn't follow through and and I see that
in so many of you you've got everything
you've got all the ingredients it's just
a lack of discipline and not making enough
it's the it's the lack of because you're not
motivated you stop and lack of motivation isn't
a good enough reason you have to follow through
so how do you do it how do you how do you uh how
do you stay disciplined how do you stay focused
when you're not getting results when you're
not seeing the wins how do you stay disciplined
okay so let me give you a couple things first is
having a really powerful morning routine this is
a struggle for entrepreneurs because no matter how
great a day you had yesterday today is a new day
no matter how great today is tomorrow's a new day
it's like you're starting over every day you go to
an event or you watch a video get all inspired and
you expect it to last and then tomorrow you wake
up it's like oh how come I don't feel the same way
as I did yesterday and then that creates a cycle
of procrastination instead of actually following
through so the morning routine really matters what
is it that gets you feel inspired motivated
creative ready to go so that you go off and
have a much better day for me two of the things
that I find the most valuable are in my morning
routine one is music so I put on music right away
it's the fastest way to change your state put on
songs that make you move that make you dance and
make you wanna just change your state because you
wake up tired and no energy like let's go we gotta
demand Excellence from ourselves and so music is
the fastest way to get your body into a different
state um and the second in my morning routine is
to do a believe walk and that's 20 minutes to an
hour every day I walk I go to Tim Hortons I grab
a cup of coffee and spend you know two bucks on it
and I think about my day how do I want my day to
go what how do I want to be intentional about the
day so we're not waking up like an accident most
people wake up like an accident fall into their
day look at other people you load your phone you
write other people's agenda for your time and then
you don't follow through and so having that as
part of my morning routine really helps me so what
is your morning routine the most important thing
that you need to do is the thing that makes you
feel important vibrant that today's gonna matter
put that into your morning routine instead
of hoping that it happens that's why I make
so many videos too there's content for you every
day if you need me in your life or you need the
people that I profoundly there's something every
single day for you across my channels so there's
no excuse for you not to get the the inspiration
and the motivation and the tactics that you need
to make your dreams happen so that's step number
one is have have a powerful morning routine step
number two is create a calendar you know what's
in your calendar I'm making videos today because
it's in my calendar today's a Tuesday when I'm
recording this and Tuesday is my YouTube day
there's a lot of stuff happening in my life
there's a lot of stuff happening in my business uh
you know right now we're we're at um my my wife's
parents house and they're delivering a couch
you see that they're delivering a couch here it's
a delivering a couch and they're helping I'm here
making content because Tuesday is my YouTube day
you know there's so many other things I could be
doing right now if I was left to my own devices
I'd say I have something more important to do I
need to be doing X but because this has been
scheduled in my calendar I'm going to follow
through and make videos how have I made you know
12 000 videos because it's in my calendar it's
been in my calendar for years to make videos
so create a calendar especially with the things
that you know you need to do that you're afraid to
do I'm still afraid to make videos guys you know
again 12 000 videos later I'm still afraid to make
videos why because I want these videos to be the
best I've ever done because I want to show up with
more care more heart more passion I hope that this
is a video that forces you you know to take some
kind of action I wanted to be the best one that
I've done and so I I'm mini procrastinate before
making videos on a Tuesday every week I have a
mini mini procrastination the only difference is
my procrastination is you know 10 minutes instead
of days 10 days and then it doesn't happen right
and so whatever you are procrastinating on that
you know is important that you're just afraid
of you put it in your calendar and you block
off time and that allows you the creativity
and the space and suffocates the excuses
for you not to follow through and then step number
three so one have a morning routine right that
sets you up to create that gets you inspired
makes you feel like you're important today's
gonna matter two you create a schedule for when
you're gonna do the things especially the scary
things on your list and then three you have to
teach yourself that you do the things that are in
your calendar you said you're gonna do it you put
in your calendar you get it done even if you're
tired even if you feel overwhelmed you can change
your calendar for tomorrow or you can change your
calendar for next week but don't trust yourself
or listen to yourself when you're feeling low
when you're feeling overwhelmed
and you said you were gonna do it
because what happens is the next time you say
you're going to do something you put in your
calendar you don't trust it you're going to
follow through because you haven't followed
through the last 20 times so be very careful
about what you put into your calendar and when
it's in there you have to go off and do it make
those three changes in your life morning routine
create a schedule do what's in your schedule
the only thing you're missing is discipline
again you've got the heart you've got the
creativity you've got the passion you've
got the willingness to serve you know you can
do more you want to create an amazing life for
yourself your family the people around you like
you know you've got this thing is you know you've
got this thing I don't need to tell you this you
know that you've got something amazing inside you
and yet it's not happening consistently enough you
have to stop jumping from high to high to high and
and wondering why you don't feel motivated today
there's nothing wrong with you this is normal
discipline put it into your life
and watch your entire life change
because you made it this far in a video I
want to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the work to
actually get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here all the
way to the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you somewhere
on the screen in a future video because you are
awesome to get 10 more amazing rules from Andrew
huberman check the video right there next to me
I think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there if people out there
think that the moment you start achieving some
success that things are going to get easier it
gets worse there are more opportunities and
therefore your structure gets disrupted more
email more texts come in more amazing possible
relationships and places to eat and things to do